[Applause]
this morning we come together as one
nation blessed to live in freedom and
grateful to worship and peace as
everybody knows my family our great
country and your president have been put
through a terrible ordeal by some very
dishonest and corrupt people they have
done everything possible to destroy us
and by so doing very badly hurt our
nation they know what they are doing is
wrong but they put themselves far ahead
of our great country weeks ago and again
yesterday courageous Republican
politicians and leaders had the wisdom
fortitude and strength to do what
everyone knows was right I don't like
people who use their faith as
justification for doing what they know
is wrong nor do I like people who say I
pray for you when they know that that's
not so so many people have been hurt and
we can't let that go on and I'll be
discussing that a little bit later at
the White House we're grateful to the
people in this room for the love they
show to religion not one religion but
many religions they're brave they're
brilliant they're fighters they like
people and sometimes they hate people
I'm sorry I apologize I'm trying to
learn
it's not easy it's not easy
[Applause]
when they impeach you for nothing then
you're supposed to like them it's not
easy folks I do my best
you better get out and vote on November
3rd cuz you have a lot of people out
there that aren't liking what we're
doing
you